So now that we have an idea
of we might use this data
let's actually build the maze
from our PList and our JSON file.
Now before we do that if we
go back to our PList file I
want to make sure everyone
notices that the root of this
PList file is a dictionary
instead of an array.
And this is also true of the JSON
file because the first and the last
characters are these curly braces,
which are indicative of an JSON object,
and a JSON object can be converted quite
easily into a dictionary and SWIFT.
Now the first thing we've done is to
find this enum called MazeCellDirection.
The most important thing about this enum
is that's it's raw type is of Int, and
what this thing is going to allow us
to do is it's giving us values 0 and
now it's going to be 1, 2, and 3, and
these will map to the indexes
in these boolean arrays.
So instead of having to refer
to the first element as the 0th
element we can use easier to read names
like top, right, bottom and left.
So this is a little trick
that I've used many of times.
I'd recommend you to try it yourself.
Then as we said both in the PList and
the JSON file these
things are dictionaries.
So we're going to start with
a function that contains a dictionary,
and we're going to return a string, and
the string we're going to return is
going to be really, really long, but
it's going to be what allows us to
visualize it here as opposed to how we
visualized it in the actual maze app.
The first thing we want to do is
make sure that the keys exist.
So we need to have a rowCount,
a columnCount, and
cellData, and if we have all of those
key value pairs, then let's make
our maze string a really, really
long string representing the maze.
Now this function here
the makeMazeString function
is where all the magic happens.
First thing we do is initialize a string
called finalstring to the empty string,
and then what we're going to do
is we're going to loop through
row by row to create our string.
So imagine here that we're looking at
the first row, and for each row we're
going to pass through the column data
three times, and I'll show you why.
The first time we're going to create
the top section of the string.
So that's created the top section
of this first row of grid cells.
The second time we go through the
columns we're going to create the middle
section, and there's our middle
section for this row of grid cells,
and then the third time we'll
create the bottom section.
And so for each pass that we're making
we're appending to the string, and
when we get to the end of a section
to get to the new line here you'll
notice that back in the code
we're adding a new line.
So let's look at that now.
And there you can see.
So this is our first pass,
then our new line, our second pass,
another new line, and then our
third pass, and the final new line.
Now you may have noticed the special
case where if the row is one and
the column is 0 we're going to
insert this little star icon for
the middle section, and we'll see what
that looks like in just a second.
And the reason we did this is mainly for
show.
We just wanted to more closely mimics
one of the mazes from the maze app.
Now these next two functions make top or
bottom section, and
make middle section they're what
actually looks at the array of bools and
determines which kind of
string we want to append.
So is it a string that contained walls,
or
a string that doesn't contain any walls.
Then when we finally make it to the
bottom here we can create our maze in
three lines of code.
Not a bad day's work.
So this looks similar to what we saw for
the student's PList example.
We're creating the path to Maze1.PList,
and then we're loading this into
a dictionary instead of an array,
and then we call our function
VisualizeMaze with the dictionary
that we've loaded from the PList.